your dog plays a prominent role on your
Instagram I want to show you some rap
dogs some of them you probably already
know and I just want you to react to one
window bounce I want you to say if you
got any stories about them I want you to
say if you want to adopt them I want to
say if maybe they don't have it first
we got push it to you CJ tell me about
CJ this dog has probably got countless
bags of cocaine mined in this bag is
probably like smuggling coke to from
Bolivia with this dog so he's probably
with that dog is a dad already knows
that bag is the line [ __ ] America's
Most Wanted how about your boy riff
Raff's Jody husky [ __ ] that was a dog
like this they chased me to school every
day we named him Jack the wolf I believe
he was a man up in the Siberian or maybe
an Alaskan Malamute or something so we
ran from him all the time this guy
doesn't say rap dog but he does say riff
raff stone right riff raff is my homie
and riff raff was all pilot all three
you look at this other dog says here's
your friend Wiz Khalifa's Vincent you
know Vincent yeah [ __ ] though I gave
with mr. really yeah okay that's a
revelation I gave the data this is a is
from SD bullies all my dogs are from SD
buddies we got a real good relationship
with those guys and when Vincent's
letter came out I picked them out of the
pack and I'm like yo dad guys and like
you like nothing imma give them to my
brother no sir
mainly because he just had bad and I'm
like y'all should all just come up
together right now he's also it's
working and you see him chillin in the
lowrider with a bandana so I don't know
like he's complaining about his life so
you know I did that for him and enjoy it
2 Chainz is trapping trapping trapping
the Frenchie so of course I'm winning
and happy Pepe's not looking up but from
his build I'm gonna assume that he's a
Frenchie and I'm an advocate for all
bully breeds off so looks like he's
having a good time he's only got one
chain on with his two dogs so maybe he's
gonna buy another chance for happy
endings to change but send two chains
always wears one chain too though I
noticed yeah I did across and people
always think like Oh two chains that
must be like to change but he always
wears that he always wears one chain
Jimmy's got like a while at you
he's the choice yeah like a chain that
we don't know about alright and then
finally Joe Budden's Harlem well all
those posted Michael [ __ ] was it all of
those dead he's ever direction he's
aware they is a hip-hop he's a rat dog
and he's chilling out on the couch he
knows that it's not been him to go to
the studio it's for Joe to go and he's
just going waiting on snakes